um with this new album
um talk about what was what's the
motivation behind the title
i love the cover from here on out from
here on out
in the cover i think there's a lot of
there's got it there's a lot of meaning
wrapped up in that cover too yeah it is
it's like and and well it goes for
everybody even like whether you're a
rapper or you're
just a nine-to-five worker with kids or
something it's like
i feel like a big part of life that a
lot of people don't try to work on is
balance
yep balance and balance is very very
important that's why when they say time
is money they're really talking about
balance and that picture just shows
balance
because it's like how do i balance this
[ __ ] out where i don't
do i'm not too much in the streets where
i get caught up or i'm not
too much into music where i forgot about
my people you know what i'm saying it's
like it's just a balance
that's why and i had a hard time from
leaving the streets and [ __ ] like that
so
i just told myself like from here on out
like i'm
i gotta give more percentage to my music
than i am in the street
yeah man i i was gonna say because i
heard you say that earlier like
have you noted because you know if if
you just kind of see what's been going
on right
there's been a lot of people getting
caught up with cases and
the fed [ __ ] people dying people getting
killed bro like the same [ __ ] um
company two two empire artists you know
vaughn was with empire
yeah yeah yeah and uh
it's just it's just crazy because
i saw um i think it might have been meek
someone just said that uh being a rapper
is the most dangerous job in the world
rangers drop it's a dangerous job if you
from the streets is a dangerous job but
also if you're not
cause aren't you a target yeah you're a
target like if you if you're on if you i
feel like any anywhere you go
if you go to a different city it's like
oh this guy's in town
yeah that might be you know a lick for
someone to hit
and then like it's a it's a target
because like the [ __ ] you did before
you know what i'm saying they know you
were super active they know you was
doing this like if you from a
notorious gang you for sure talk it just
triple it you know what i'm talking
about it just triples it like vaughn was
a notorious
his hood is everywhere worldwide so he
did his was tripled
but then but then again at the same time
is it is it never how do you say that
inevitable inevitable right
because like you could be you could be
so on point
like so like think you're on point your
homies on point but
a lot of the times it's unexpected like
it's like
vaughn that was quan around homie but i
don't speak about who it is but
that wasn't his enemies like that ain't
you know what i'm saying that ain't the
other side
of the enemies in the city right it was
some rapper [ __ ]
that's what's crazy rapper [ __ ] nipsey
wasn't his enemies you know what i'm
saying
like you're just and is it is it it's
unexpected
unexpected yeah yeah no definitely like
that's what i wanted to ask you about
because i
obviously you know your track record is
clear like
do you find yourself maybe like
having your circle become a little bit
smaller or maybe watching out like yo
man i might not need to go
do a b and c or be around a b and c
anymore like i used to be
just because now i got so much more to
lose yeah yeah i'll be like that
but it's like that [ __ ] that i did
like back then you know what i'm saying
before the rapture took off
it um like i don't need to be in the
hood you know what i'm saying i don't
need to
prove anything or do anything because a
lot of the times it's
it's not my homies you hear about
rappers saying their homies hating them
because they be like oh man he just a
rapper he's not in the hood he never
would he do for the hood but it's the
other way around i'll be in my
section and my homies like what you
doing here man or like damn don't you
do that music [ __ ] bro [ __ ] this [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and they
actually tell me to like
like what i'm doing here and [ __ ] like
that so i guess that that would just be
my advice man it's like you got
something special bro
sure and like i think that we've seen a
lot of examples
this year that that has just kind of
shown like
it might like [ __ ] you come from that
background
staying out the way might be the way you
know what i'm saying for sure
off smarter who's smarter for show for
show